en este vídeo quiero ver un montón de
ejercicios acerca de factorización creo
que ya estamos preparados para hacer un
buen de ejercicios con todos estos temas
que hemos visto voy a tomar x cuadrada +
4x igual a 21 y cómo resuelvo esta
ecuación pues lo primero que tengo que
hacer es pasar todos de una de la
ecuación para igualar a cero así que lo
primero que hay que hacer es restar 21
de ambos lados de la ecuación para que
me quede una ecuación cuadrática
igualada a cero a ver entonces déjenme
ver que me quedo x cuadrada más 4 x
menos 21 le voy a quitar 21 a esta parte
y del otro lado también voy a quitar 21
recuerda que hay que hacer lo mismo de
los dos lados de la ecuación por lo
tanto me queda x cuadrada más 4 x menos
21 igual a 0 ya por fin está igual a 0 y
ahora me fijo en lo que me queda del
lado izquierdo
tengo una expresión la cual la puedo
factorizar en dos binomios como lo hemos
visto hasta ahorita lo que me voy a
fijar es en dos números que sumados me
den cuatro sumado sobre esta dos me den
cuatro y que su vez multiplicados me den
menos 21
entonces por b es igual a menos 21 y ya
más b es igual a 4 b es igual a 4 y que
dos números multiplicados me dan menos
21 bueno 21 se puede factorizar en 21 y
1 y en 7 y 30 7 y 3 y los restos metan 4
por lo tanto ya encontré los dos números
que yo quiero 7 y 3 además date cuenta
que menos 21 tiene signo negativo por lo
tanto me queda perfecto porque entonces
voy a tener al 7 positivo y al 3
negativo tal vez que multiplicados me
dan menos 21 y sumados me dan 4 y bueno
una vez creados encontré me doy cuenta
que la expresión que tengo la izquierda
se va a ver de la siguiente manera x + 7
x x menos 3 igual a 0 y tengo dos
binomios multiplicados igualados a cero
lo que quiere decir que o el primero es
cero o el segundo cero recuerda que dos
cosas multiplicadas a cero o la primera
es cero o la segunda es cero
entonces me queda que x + 7 es igual a
cero o x menos 3 es igual a cero y si de
aquí despejó yo a x me queda que x es
igual a menos 7 y en el otro lado me
queda
x es igual a 3 si yo paso en menos 3 del
otro lado sumando y ya tengo aquí las
dos raíces de esta ecuación x igual a
menos 7 y x igual a tres son raíz vamos
a ver si funcionan y no me equivoque
nada menos 7 al cuadrados 49 más 4 x
menos 7 lo cual me va a dar menos 28
esto me tiene que dar
21 49 menos 28 y en efecto fuente 9
menos 28 21 y por lo tanto si funciona
vamos a ver con 33 al cuadrado 29 más 12
me da 21 entonces perfecto también con 3
funciona bueno pues ahora vamos a ver
otro ejemplo el siguiente ejemplo
también tiene que ver con una ecuación
me voy a tomar x cuadrada más 49 igual a
14 x y bueno que es lo primero que
tenemos que hacer cuando tenemos este
tipo de ecuación es pasar todo de un
lado de la ecuación para igualar la 0
por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer aquí es
pasar el 14 x del otro lado y lo voy a
pasar con el signo contrario me queda x
cuadrado menos 14 x más 49 igual a cero
y otra vez me voy a fijar en dos números
tales que
multiplicarse en 49 y a sumar se mete en
-14 al sumar se vuelve a estar set y
bueno para encontrarlos lo que se me
hace adecuado es pensar en los factores
del 49 en qué números podemos
descomponer el 49 si te das cuenta el 49
es un número que no tiene muchos
factores 49 solamente se puede
descomponer en 149 y 7 de hecho es 7 al
cuadrado por lo tanto déjenme escribirlo
por acá necesitamos dos números que
multiplicados en el 49 y sumados me den
menos 14 y mis factores son 17 49 49 y 1
nunca me van a dar suma 2 resta 2 14
sin embargo 7 menos 7 si lo dan fíjate
que como 49 tiene signo positivo
necesitábamos tener el mismo signo por
lo tanto tiene que ser siete y siete o
menos siete menos siete pero como la
suma es negativa por lo tanto tiene que
ser menos 7 y menos 7 por lo tanto es lo
mismo que x menos 7 por x menos 7 y eso
tiene que ser igual a cero o dicho de
otra manera es lo mismo que x menos 7 l
cuadrado y esto es igual a 0 y de aquí
ya es muy fácil despejar a x porque si
pasamos del otro lado el cuadrado va a
pasar como raíz cuadrada o dicho de otra
manera siempre excesivamente tengo que
escribir lo que está dentro del
paréntesis igual a 20 x menos 7 es igual
a cero de aquí ya obtengo mi raíz x
menos 7 es igual a cero si solo si x es
igual a 7 es decir estoy pasando del
otro lado el 7 y ya con esto tengo la
solución de mi otra ecuación si paso el
7 de otro lado me queda que x es igual a
7 y ya obtuve la solución de este
segundo ejercicio que tengo aquí así que
vamos a hacer un tercer ejercicio y ese
tercer ejercicio me va a dar pie a
analizar algo que vamos a ver en un
futuro este ejercicio es x cuadrada
menos 64 igual a 0 y bueno lo primero
que quiero que te des cuenta es que aquí
no tenemos término x me refiero a la x
con la potencia 1 y sin embargo si lo
puedo poner creo que va a ser mucho más
sencillo si de una vez le pongo el
término x es decir escribir esto como x
cuadrada más 0 veces x menos 64 y
a 0 y es que date cuenta que 0 por equis
va a ser lo mismo que 0 entonces llegó a
esto que tengo aquí arriba x cuadrada
menos 64 y bueno ahora sí voy a pensar
en dos números que multiplicados me dé
64 negativo y a su vez sumados me den 0
o dicho de otra manera estoy buscando
dos números que a - bm den 0 uno
positivo y uno negativo porque mi
resultado de la multiplicación es
negativo y aquí obtengo que a tiene que
ser igual a ver o dicho de otra manera
estoy buscando dos números iguales
solamente que uno va a tener signo
positivo y el otro va a tener signo
negativo y con esto voy a poder
factorizar esta ecuación a ver dos
números que me den multiplicado 64 y
sean iguales pues es 8 y 8 pero si te
das cuenta 64 negativo por lo tanto esto
tener uno positivo y el otro negativo
entonces es menos 8 por 8 y entonces ya
que tengo estos dos números recuerda que
ya podemos factorizar esta ecuación esto
es lo mismo que x menos 8 que multiplica
a x más 8 y ya encontré la solución de
esta ecuación que por cierto este tipo
de factorización se le conoce
una diferencia de cuadrados cuando
tenemos algo de la forma más ve por al
menos ven su resultado es a cuadrado
menos be cuadrada o dicho de otra manera
lo tenemos algo de la forma cuadrada
menos de cuadrada lo podemos factorizar
como a más b por a menos b fíjate aquí
tenemos el cuadrado de 1 - el cuadrado
de otro y precisamente por eso se llama
una diferencia de cuadrados voy a hacer
otro ejercicio pero en esta ocasión no
te voy a decir qué tipo de ejercicio es
vamos a pensar un poco cómo podemos
resolver el siguiente ejercicio dado
todas las herramientas que ya tenemos mi
siguiente ejercicio va a ser este con un
color distinto x cuadrada a menos 24 x
más 144 igual a cero como lo resolvemos
bueno lo primero que voy a hacer esto de
siempre buscar dos números que
multiplicados me den 144 y que a su vez
sumados me den menos 24 sumado sobre
estados y bueno fácilmente me vas a
decir ah pero estos 12 x 12 de hecho es
menos 12 x menos 12 porque menos 12
menos 12 me da 24
entonces esto lo podemos actualizar como
x menos 12 por x menos 12 o dicho otra
manera estos x
elevado al cuadrado igual a cero y aquí
ya es muy fácil resolver esta ecuación x
menos dos es igual a cero y entonces yo
obtengo yo la solución recuerda que lo
único que había que hacer es igualar a
cero la parte de adentro del cuadrado
porque al final lo que hay que hacer es
pasar el otro lado el 12 x es igual a 12
y es la solución de esperas pero espera
date cuenta que aquí no igual es 0 en
este ejercicio que tenía que arriba me
faltó sacar mis raíces
estos x menos 8 x x más 8 igual a cero
te acuerdas y ahora lo que voy a hacer
es como tengo dos binomios igualados en
cero
voy a igualar cada uno de estos binomios
a cero porque recuerda que dos números
multiplicados entre sí es igual a cero
si el primero es igual a cero o el
segundo sube a cero y si el primero es
igual a cero me sale que x es igual a 8
o en su dado casos y el segundo es igual
a cero me queda que x es igual a menos 8
y ya aquí tengo las dos raíces de esta
ecuación regresando al ejercicio que
estábamos haciendo me queda que x es
igual a 12 es mi solución y por último
vamos a hacer un ejercicio muy sencillo
y muy rápido tengo 4x cuadrada menos 25
igual a 0 qué tipo de ecuación
cuadrática es
y me vas a decir pero esta es una
diferencia de cuadrados de la que
acabamos de ver aquí tengo el cuadrado
de 1 - el cuadrado del otro y por lo
tanto si yo saco la raíz cuadrada de 4 x
cuadrada y de 25 voy a poder obtener la
solución si a cuadrado es igual a 4 x
cuadrada su raíz es 2x y la raíz de 25
es 5 por lo tanto recuerda que a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada lo podemos ver
como a más b que multiplica a menos b y
ya tengo a am y ya tengo a b por lo
tanto ya puedo factorizar esta
diferencia de cuadrados que yo tengo
aquí esto me queda 12 x 5 que multiplica
a 2 x 5 y esto es igual a 0 y entonces
tengo que hacer cada uno de estos
binomios igual a cero si hago el primer
binomio ueda a cero me queda 2x más 5 es
igual a 0 y de una vez déjame escribirlo
para que no nos confundamos 2 x 5 es
igual a cero o en su dado casos igual al
segundo binomio igual a cero me queda 2x
menos 5 es igual a 0 y resolver estudia
es muy sencillo voy a pasar primero es
menos 5 del otro lado con signo
contrario 2x es igual a menos 5 y
después voy a dividir todo entre 2 si me
queda que x es igual a menos 5 medios o
en su dado caso
a mí no me igualado pero me queda que 2x
es igual a 5 y si divido ambas partes de
la ecuación entre 2 me queda que x es
igual a 5 medios y bueno ya con esto
resolví un buen de ejercicios sobre este
tema de la factorización espero te hayan
servido